a judge has ordered Donald Trump to
dissolve the Trump organization I didn't
believe it when I first heard it because
this is the most egregious action I
think we've seen yet it's not just
trying to criminally charge it which is
crazy don't get me wrong but they're
outright saying they are they're going
to shut down this what multi-billion
dollar real estate company at least it's
just in New York so we'll see how this
plays out Trump is going to appeal but
man I don't see it stopping here it is
not even 2024 yet but wait many of you
may be saying well what's going to
happen I mean Trump's leading in the
polls he is Joe Biden's failing among
Black and Latino voters but now we're
learning that the classified document
probe into Joe Biden is expanding and
Gavin Newsom in the prediction markets
is starting to go up so maybe I'll be
I'll be really happy if by next year I'm
I'm right that Joe Biden ends up being
removed or drops out or something
because I'm like crossing my fingers I'm
like please don't be wrong because I
just cannot see a path for Joe by the
moving forward we're going to talk about
this plus a whole bunch of other stories
we've got New York I think there what's
New York pain Libya is it a billion
dollars yeah a billion dollars a billion
dollars over the next uh three years wow
to house illegal immigrants well we are
going to talk about all that before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com click timcast irlx Miami and
pick up your tickets to see Patrick Bet
David James O'Keefe Matt Gates Luke
Krakowski me Ian Crossland plus a whole
bunch of extra guests we got Alex Stein
he's gonna be doing an opening set it's
going to be fantastic we hope to see you
there October 6 in Miami so it is coming
up but also click join us become a
member to support our work directly if
you think the work we do is important
and we need your support because it's
basically how we run the company but as
a member you get access to our Discord
server where you can hang out with
like-minded individuals who are building
culture there's an early show there's an
after show where you can hang out with
people who are discussing all of these
issues Beyond just the conversation we
have and they're working on projects
they're making music and doing really
cool things as a member of the Discord
you can even submit questions and call
into the uncensored portion of the show
which is Monday through Thursday and
honestly it's one of the most fun so I
really do think tonight's members only
uncensored is going to be truly epic
because joining us we have a man who
tried to warn US 10 years ago Carl
Benjamin thank you for having me who are
you what do you do uh I'm the director
of lordsees.com not a very controversial
person
I haven't really had much press tension
so I'm very thankful for this
opportunity that's right absolutely
appreciate it I'm shy
so when I when I first started after I
left uh fusion and I started producing
YouTube videos I got a tremendous help
from Carl who hit me up and said are you
you're doing good work yeah I like what
you did I appreciate your honesty would
you like to make a video for my channel
and you had hundreds of thousands of
subscribers I had like none and then
after I made the video for your channel
it put me over 100 000 subs and I got my
silver medal so I really I really
appreciate it anytime excited to have
you here man this is going to be a blast
and uh Libby of course is here I asked
her already I'm already here yes yeah
well I asked you about the money because
it's yours Millennial story well it is a
post-millennial story yeah a billion
dollars I'm good I'm Libby Emmons I'm
here representing the post-millennial
and humanevents.com right on Phil's here
of course hello everybody my name is
Phil Labonte lead singer of All That
Remains very failed musician
anti-communist and counter revolutionary
that's stain that is absolutely staying
that's amazing it's like a title before
your name fail the musician that's
brilliant and you just got a new gold
record I did uh we were I was just
informed today classic failed musician I
was just informed today that uh another
single has gone gold so that I think
it's five gold and the platinum and you
know that's a lot of family yeah I
believe I'm hanging out with this guy
you know I appreciate you looking down
looking you know coming to the plebs and
hanging so that's right Hannah Claire's
here hey I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com I'm grateful to
be here with this lack of musical talent
and of course our favorite DJ Serge is
here too I am man I knew you did
something in music field I just never
never put my finger on it anyways let's
get started keep trying buddy find
success man all right let's jump into
this first story this is this is
absolutely insane this is from messenger
politics Donald Trump's New York
business Empire must be dissolved judge
rules legal experts have described the
extraordinarily rare order issued by a
New York judge aimed at Trump's major
businesses as the corporate death
penalty crazy look at this a New York
judge on Tuesday canceled the
certificates of the key businesses
behind Donald Trump's Empire ordering a
quick timeline to dissolve the Trump
organization and other corporate
entities okay
there's so much here first I don't know
exactly how Trump runs his businesses
but I have to imagine Trump is a New
York guy famously coming in and saving
the city and the state which means I'm
assuming his businesses are registered
many of them in New York and I would
imagine are operating as a foreign
corporation in other states that's what
it's called so you thought you file that
now considering how long he's been
around I would not be surprised if the
bulk of his business may actually be out
of Delaware or Nevada We we'll see but
this is
this is New York
Trump has there's documentaries about
how New York was failing and Trump came
in and said I'm going to turn this city
around and he did and he's got how many
buildings does he have in New York I
mean official Trump buildings are two of
them well he has like a whole thing on
the West Side there's a bunch of Trump
Towers on the west side yeah well he's
got like a whole Enterprise over there
um and then he's also got the Trump
Tower which is right I want to say it's
right near Columbus Circle I know that
I've been there before I've got my Maga
hat there in 2017. right yeah that's
that's the that's the International
Hotel the Trump International yeah and
then he also has a Trump Tower
on Fifth Avenue I went to a party in a
penthouse there was it was amazing this
is John golden Trump building there I
was like you know what I think I'm
getting the Maga hat and so I just
walked in it was awesome it was amazing
yeah I mean Trump did an awful lot for
the city he was born there he was raised
there and these are people who have been
determined to take him down Leticia
James the Attorney General of New York
state ran her campaign on Destroy Donald
Trump so did stupid Alvin brag in
Manhattan who's of course working to
destroy Donald Trump all of these people
they just hate him so much this is this
is it's it's not it doesn't seem to have
any real legal basis even this judge
hates Trump and has said so before
so they're saying that uh basically we
have this from CNBC Trump and Company
liable for fraud in New York lawsuit
judge rules this is not even a criminal
proceeding that's right this is a civil
case and they are so so look at this the
messenger says 10 corporate entities djt
revocable trust revocable trust right
I'm assuming that has something to do
with his personal life which is likely
where he holds certain properties in his
personal portfolio or family not related
to uh so it depends I mean you never
really no I mean you could do a lot of
stuff with trust but I'm assuming the
trust is probably for holding his
property a personal stuff the Trump
organization the Trump organization LLC
those right there I mean that's that's
it that's that's Trump the Trump
organization this is this is nuts and
then they mentioned a bunch of others
like djt Holdings managing member LLC
some of these are you know whatever 401
North Wabash Venture LLC this is
basically a a just a building Trump Old
Post Office LL LC 40 Wall Street LLC
basically when you buy big property you
create it yeah you create a private
entity that owns that property why okay
if uh if you regular citizens sir many
of you own homes if you own two houses
and someone slips and falls in one they
can sue and take your take both your
houses you create a corporate entity it
Shields you to a certain degree so it
always makes more sense to start a
Company the company owns the property
you own the company and that limits
liability hey how about that so this
means they're canceling the business
that owns a building yeah so Trump has a
lot of these corporations that own
buildings and they're canceling them on
him
um I wonder what's gonna happen to
Mar-A-Lago well uh Mar-A-Lago is Florida
and so don Jr owns it I believe really I
believe he turned it over to Don Jr a
good few years ago so they say
outstanding I wouldn't be surprised if
he doesn't own as much after his uh term
as president right maybe Bedminster I
don't see Bedminster on there so they
say Trump's attorney Alina Haba vowed to
appeal the decision which she called
fundamentally flawed at every level the
fact that this court summarily found
that there is no question of fact
finding in part that Mar-A-Lago is worth
approximately 20 million dollars and
issue a decision of this magnitude as an
affront to our legal system we intend to
immediately appeal this decision because
president Trump and his family like
every American business owner is
entitled to their day in court so it was
a summary judgment
that doesn't seem at all reasonable well
I mean okay I gotta be I didn't even
know that that doesn't this story is is
breaking but hold on hold on they say
judge Arthur engarin canceled New York
business advocates for Trump trump
organization other defendants including
two of his sons wow and they dismissed
the lawsuit against Ivanka I think in
June but is this was this a summary
judgment the spokes were so this is
attorney general Leticia James she filed
this and then the judge just banged the
devil yeah uh and Gordon granting
partial summary judgment to James the
case found that Trump made false
misleading valuations this means Trump
didn't even come and argue the judge
just so they filed their paperwork they
file their arguments and the judge goes
nah done yo wow yeah that's really
messed up if they are if they're you
know if they can actually essentially
take the property by a summary judgment
I mean then obviously that that means
that no one's property is safe anymore
well which is of course what Trump's
been saying this whole time is that
they're you know he's between
the the essential police and law fair
State and the rest of us I I I I gotta
stop this is this is crazy look at this
and Grand also ordered sanctions of 7
500 for five attorneys who represented
the Trump defendants for making
frivolous and previously rejected
arguments in court filings this is crazy
you're not allowed to you're not allowed
to represent Trump they're doing that in
Georgia too I mean they went for his
attorney to call any to call this
unprecedented is an understatement of
the highest order unprecedented
understatement I mean it it really is
and again this and not not that I'm
trying to let you get Tim fired up again
but you know if the government is taking
people's property and stuff then the
government is acting lawlessly what
recourse do the people have if you can't
rely on the law and where does this head
I'm not going to say it but I don't see
the off ramp well
sure I think um
the the framing is wrong right because
this isn't the government because the
government implies kind of a neutral
entity that
um that takes bipartisan consideration
of all parties in the country and the
people being themselves are kind of
non-partisan entity that just exist
separate from the state it's it's like
an old it's kind of an archaic way look
at what what you have is a left-wing
Insurgent movement 100 that has taken
over your country and it's now
persecuting the former president yeah
this this no I I like
I it you can't overstate just how over
your country is
I mean it's not just bad right a country
is predicated on Goodwill between both
parties right now you you don't have
Goodwill what you have is an active
persecution of the former president man
your country is over and now what's
being settled is who gets to rule over
the ruins all right look look you know I
certainly think we have our issues here
in the United States but I think you
know hey Phil someone's a little salty
about 70 76 over here oh man I was gonna
say I mean the man who comes from Empire
but I'm I'm very much in the dock that
hey 7076 was a good thing and Trump
should never have had a mug shot no I
agree you're living in a Banana Republic
and you're I've heard it's being
persecuted I've heard Carl say that the
United States is actually the the total
fulfillment of the English common law of
what England was supposed to be before
so I I know that he doesn't have the uh
so it's so it's it's constitutional
republic Envy
well because I mean this isn't happening
in my country no you you're your
government's just going after businesses
like Rumble sure that's correct that's
not my property I don't know what to
tell you I mean I think you're right
because uh attorney general Leticia
James campaigned on being an activists
she didn't say I'm gonna uphold the law
and be representation of fairness she
said we are going to disrupt the system
we're going to go after Trump and she is
open about her her preferences for
left-wing causes I mean there are a lot
of organizations that she is
specifically persecuting these people
are fighting a war against you yes you
do understand that they're actively in
arms against you with all of the legal
mechanisms they can find this is a
cultural revolution it yeah it is and
that they're going to extirpate Trump
from public life as much as they can
they're going to take everything from
him as much as they can and anyone who
stands in Alliance with him I mean Rudy
Giuliani for me is crazy the fact that
you know he's got a mugshot too that
that was that was America's mail wasn't
it he's the greatest yeah he was he was
the guy at 9 11.
he's he's the guy who ridden New York of
crime right like it's before 9 11 he
cleaned up the city amazingly well right
he got rid of the mobs and stuff right
and it's really Juliana can essentially
be paraded around in Chains like the
failed opposition in a Roman civil war
with Donald Trump and everyone else
around him I mean what kind of country
failed Roman civil or tell me more well
I mean well okay uh in yeah
time in Civil War basically the uh the
losing party get killed right but that's
well that's the the they're on the path
to doing that they're not going to kill
Donald Trump they're just going to ruin
him so he's like oh oh blind belisarius
begging for pennies outside I don't know
that they wouldn't kill him should it
look like he's going to win
if they could they would but they won't
they might try and kill him before I
mean did you see him what's her name um
Megan Kelly was talking about that yeah
no no they're going to do this she was
saying that she's concerned that people
that people are going to try and
assassinate Trump yeah I think I think
the time for that has passed I think
they've got the machine in motion and
what they're going to do is just
systematically grind down Trump and
everyone associated with him everything
Maga everything protesters they're going
to stigmatize it's Terrors but this is
why they've been doing already yeah and
so I I do think it's not just Trump I
think this is what we see with Russell
Brand as well there's it makes no sense
to me that they all of a sudden decided
to start investigating and caring about
Russell Brand did decades ago one of the
time and they certainly didn't care and
they've protected much worse the thing
about Russell Brand though is this was
an intentional media takedown you had
the times in London they started doing
this investigation into Russell Brand
they're the ones who contacted these
women the women said they were only
prepared to come forward after they'd
been contacted by press they also said
that they were only coming forward
because they were encouraged to come
forward now in as a reaction to Bran's
new found success they didn't like that
that's what was published in the times
and then you had right after that you
had NBC start contacting
um all of the advertisers who sponsored
brand on YouTube you know and like on
all of his channels it was NBC reaching
out that got you know what Vivo Barefoot
or whatever else and The Sticker Mule
company to say that they were going to
disavow Brandon pull it and then after
that the news movement which is this
company that was founded in 2020
launched last year is owned by some
people who used to work for the Dow
Jones and BBC they then started going
after rumbles advertisers after Rumble
said that they backed free speech and
backed Russell Brand this other
organization went after their
advertisers this was a concerted effort
and of course you had the British
government I do we do have a story I
want to talk about in a bit about
Russell Brand but the reason I bring
this up and I think it no I think it it
it's it's warranted is because the
conversation doesn't stop with Trump
they are as you said call trying to ruin
him but this does not stop with Trump
it's it's it's especially right now as
we're entering 2024 we know that you
know what was it 2018 I said this last
night with Alex Jones and then went
after Paul Joseph Watson Alex Jones uh
uh Laura Loomer that's right Donald
Trump eventually they will get to to Joe
Rogan absolutely yeah because Joe Rogan
is has now repeated himself with Patrick
uh David saying that he would vote for
Trump over Biden I mean you cannot have
this no so they there is an effort here
and I think if you look at Julian
Assange as an example of how they deal
with this surprise surprise oh Russell
Brand me too all the stuff it is is a
similar theme Donald Trump same thing in
uh was it Bergdorf was it the yeah
Goodman's yep they said that he showed
up no one noticed and they found him
liable notice they're not doing criminal
charges in New York they're finding him
liable why because a judge can bang the
gavel you don't have the same kind of
Rights
it is genuinely terrifying however I
want to say this to you Carl
I think we're winning
I don't see it so when you look at the
culture see the evidence for it well so
so first how many of their guys are in
jail why why why is that the standard by
which we determine if we're winning or
losing what is the standard so the
standard is economic factors and
cultural factors and I think if you look
at the cultural victories particularly
pronounced ones you can see the shift in
the minds of the people and what
confidence of the people will allow
right now Joe Biden is tanking he's
sinking in the polls we're seeing woke
corporations get decimated we're seeing
indie films Skyrocket Indie artist
Skyrocket we're seeing a collective of
of uh anti-establishment individuals and
more people I'm seeing on Twitter for
instance this doctor I've retweeted who
says I was wrong in 2020 I shouldn't
have supported Biden what what many of
us experienced for me and for me in
particular I think in like 2020 when my
attitude towards Trump in 2016 was nah
yeah get out of here with this magnitude
later on was like well I'm not going to
vote for the guy but I can understand
what people are saying about him and
then in 2020
but then in 2020 I was like the agenda
he released lays out too many points
that I've agreed with and it would be
hypocritical for me to say I would not
support that
so that's that's pre-2020. now we're
seeing more people who voted for Biden
in 2020 who did not have that Revelation
now saying I totally get it I'm voting
for Trump yeah I I see these things Bud
Light Target Disney Netflix
to that as well Marriott Marriott we
need to add marriage what happened with
Marriott uh Marriott was the hotel that
canceled Andy knows talk after antifa
called and harassed them and so that
Hotel chain needs the Bud Light
treatment but look at the the rise of
the parallel economy so at first you
could argue yes we're losing because
they're debanking people they're
censoring people and there were attempts
to to counter this right parlor and then
they destroy parlor but then a couple
things happen
Carl you're back on on X your Twitter
yeah but that wasn't because
um of any Goodwill in the establishment
no of course not it's because a powerful
individual who views the world more
closely to how we view it in terms of
what should or should not be
took great risk to buy the platform to
in my opinion pursue his personal goals
but it also had a tremendous effect of
bringing back a lot of the people who
are Thanos snapped out of the
conversation so now you're back on
Twitter
right so you see a move like that Rumble
their spec deal according to the Motley
Fool Chris Chris pavlovski the CEO is a
billionaire okay I don't know how Chris
feels about me saying that but like the
Motley Fool says here's how many shares
he owns at this price
if that's true he's a tech billionaire
okay and this means when you see the
tremendous support that new platforms
are getting and the success of platforms
like the daily wire with the failures
this is why I think you see what they're
doing in New York does it is any is is
this going to help them I don't think it
helps them in the long run I think there
are a lot of communist banality of evil
types who will cheer for it no matter
what but I do think there's going to be
a lot of regular people who are going to
start going like dude this is freaking
me out you're scaring me I talk to
people touch grass as it were and I'll
say something like what do you think
about I hate Trump screw that don't care
and then their real attitude the reason
why they hate Trump and when I'm gone is
they're like I'm tired of conflict I'm
tired of the noise I'm tired of the
fighting I want stability and guess what
this doesn't stop with Trump but but the
point here is these people don't realize
they don't realize they think make Trump
go away and they leave us alone wrong no
that is wrong yeah now what I'm hearing
I'm hanging out the poker tables and
there is this lib guy and and I'm
talking to a guy in front of me who's
like a fan this guy chimes in when we're
talking about Trump and he goes look hey
I I hate Trump but you know they they
shouldn't be doing these these suits to
get him off the ballot that's that's
crazy and I'm like right what's gonna
happen is these regular people who are
begging for normalcy are now realizing
the things they're doing with shutting
down the Trump organization Prosecuting
him is the conflict and Trump is the
solution we have the situation where you
have the people who are in power
distinctly not listening to the
constituents at all on any topic on any
area of of governance whatsoever so I
think that's what we're seeing too is
we're seeing normal people be like these
lawsuits are bogus you know mutilating
kids is bogus we don't want any of that
opening the borders and destroying our
national sovereignty that's a terrible
idea you know you're seeing all of this
stuff and the more constituents speak
out which they are doing you know we see
the polling we see all this stuff we see
people speaking out against it and the
ruling class doesn't care at all you
know they're so used to just shoving
their elitist opinions down our throats
and I say this as a you know recovering
elitist they like they're shoving this
all down our throats and we're just
supposed to take it and people don't
want to take it anymore but I do
I do wonder if we're actually winning
like it it feels a lot feels a lot like
being destroyed I I think you have to be
careful of of listen Trump is ahead in
the polls yeah Trump is ahead in the
prediction markets but don't you think
they're gonna take him out don't you
think they're gonna find a way to like
I'm not that's why they're doing all of
this it's desperation it's so let's
let's let's do this I mean desperate
crazy girls who kill you still kill you
all right let's let me pull up this
story from the post millennial uh
Biden's approval rating among black
Americans down 17 points according to
NBC in fact it's so bad that Washington
Post downplayed their own polls that
showed Trump winning by 10 points 10
points CNN had a segment where they
shoot now there were two polls one said
ten and one said ninth I heard one go
ahead sorry so I I don't know how it how
it works necessarily but they have two
different polls of of you know and
that's what gets released to 538 or
that's what 538 tracks and so you have
Biden losing CNN running a segment where
they say outright in the 2020 cycle we
never saw Trump pull this well against
Biden at all in aggregate Trump is
beating Joe Biden I'm imagining these
people in New York this judge why would
he bang the gavel to destroy the Trump
organizations he's crying he's in his
room heart beating racing going am I on
the wrong side of History I can't lose
we can't lose bang the gavel in
violation of their of their of what they
once believed or whatever they thought
they believed arresting Donald Trump
arresting his lawyers finding his
lawyers this reeks of someone crying
and frantic Panic that tyranny is a
confession of weakness yes but these
people think they're fighting Nazis
they think they're saving the world from
fascism but the problem is that the
Nazis are the ones honored in Canadian
Parliament by the Prime Minister but
that's a problem for us
having a problem for them and then he
says we have to watch out for Russian
disinformation I don't think these
people truly believe they're fighting
Nazis I believe they say that I think
they really believe it I I think some of
them might but I imagine a lot of these
people
uh when when you talk to uh I've talked
to high profile celebrities musicians
rock stars actors Etc and I'm sure you
guys have your experience with them as
well where they say things like look man
I can't I can't be involved they'll come
I'll be destroyed they're they're all
likely in my opinion
high profile individuals in law
enforcement and the Judiciary
who thought to themselves
oh my God I can't believe what's
happening to my country these people
have gone crazy but if I speak up
they'll destroy me so I've got to just
keep my head down and play along and
hope I survive but uh oh they chose the
wrong side they chose the despots who
are going to lose in this country called
the United States and now they're
thinking to themselves if Trump wins
it's me
I have no choice but to do everything in
my power to make sure Trump can't do
that Trump's going to lock people up I'm
hoping so I believe there's a strong
possibility last time yeah but that was
different that was Trump thinking he
could play ball and now and and it was
not this crazy it was it was weird it
was wild but Trump said no we don't do
that we're not going to do that we're
not going to seem like the social norms
were still in place right but now
they're clearly off the table so I mean
if Trump does win and doesn't just jail
every single one of these people then
you know it's over right do you yeah do
you think he if I don't think he's got a
choice I mean what what what well there
have been a lot of times that Trump has
said that he would do something yeah he
doesn't follow through I mean it's one
of his biggest flaws I think that but I
feel like the reason that Trump behaved
the way that he did when he was in
office is because he believed that he
would be accepted by The Establishment
remember he the only reason that he ran
is because Barack Obama mocked him at
the dinner that was the last straw that
was the I truly believe that was the
last straw because he wanted to prove
that he he was worth worth their respect
that he was that he had earned and was
worth being among the elite and he
thought once I'm president they will go
ahead and accept me and that's the way
he behaved and even up to right at the
very end when he gave my uh General
Millie an award and he gave fauci own
award the day before he left office that
was because he was looking to placate
them he see I I I assume I have to
assume that he sees now that there is no
there is no route for him to be friendly
that if he gets back into office he has
to take he has to take control and he
has to destroy the the bureaucracy the
point that you're making about how he
believed that people would accept him
that has been Trump's fatal flaw his
entire life I mean all like that
Chappelle's joke that he came out of the
house to say they're all corrupt and
then went back in right he's always sort
of wanted to return to these buddies but
yeah he wants that and he's wanted that
his whole he's wanted that his whole
career like none of the you know none of
the
he was in real estate New York none of
the other real estate people or like the
you know the Architects or the
contractors or anybody they always were
talking out of two sides of their mouth
with him and he knew it yeah and he's he
hasn't liked it I mean that is Trump's
big problem is the need for approval
yeah because I mean if there's one thing
that you can say that's good about
DeSantis is he's all too autistic for
approval right well people have actually
this is a Common Thread among liberals
saying that Rhonda census is quite
literally they believe he genuinely has
autism yeah I know that's why I like him
but it's it's just not his time at the
moment but I I don't know man I I think
the the problem the problem with like
relying on like the great man to take
out the organized minority is that the
organized minority can lose lots of
times and still win or as the great man
just has to lose once then it's over
yeah well I think he lost twice I think
it's uh I mean
sorry I was gonna say to clarify when I
say we're winning that's not to say that
we own the battlefield it means that we
have been pushed back pushed back and
finally now we have routed the advancing
force and their ranks are starting to
break that means on the battlefield we
are in a weakened position but we have
begun a successful Advance against this
corrupt ideology where if this trend
continues we do win
I don't know I I think I think they'll
find a way of screwing him I think oh
sure sure but Trump's not the end-all
be-all I I think Trump is a is an avatar
of the rage felt by people in this
country for a long time and he's
absorbing more and more he's growing
bigger with each and I mean I hope so
well it it is I mean the fact that you
know Biden's approval rating among black
Americans going down at the same time
Trump is surging among black Americans
that is one of the most terrifying
statistics to Democrats it was uh it's
been reported several times Wall Street
Journal recently in the past couple of
years said if Democrats can't maintain
20 or if I'm sorry 80 if at any point
the Republicans go past 20 black support
the Democrats cannot win sure period but
the and the argument that Trump has
never been stronger but I'm very
concerned about all of the salami slice
tactics that they're going to employ you
know the ballot harvesting and whatever
else it is that they do but I uh
I'm I'm not confident what would make
you feel confident though like what
would change to make you feel confident
I mean or is it just a lost cause voting
would have to be done in person with
Pottery charts right that would make me
feel confident right I don't know while
there are all these other mechanisms I
I'm skeptical I don't think the
presidency is the end-all be-all it's
not what matters I think what matters is
the cultural shift the the problem is
the presidency has been accruing extra
powers and more Central authority over
the last few decades and so it becomes
this kind of totemic influential
position that legislates through
executive order yeah they're doing
things the way things should be done
right George Bush had a certain number
of executive orders and Obama had more
yeah Trump had more and now Biden and
Biden was unbelievably aggressive on the
first like week in the first day he had
like 20 or something yeah and then he
just carry this on literally doing
hundreds of them so it's the this this
is just what happens to Old republics
man yeah you know power centralizes they
don't last forever well let's let's
clarify
I'm not saying that the existing
structure of the United States is
preserved I'm saying there will be
something new coming from it I believe
the left are reactionary and and it's
always interesting how you define how
they try to Define what reactionary is
right the left will say we're reaction
areas because it makes no sense uh the
left explicitly claims to be Progressive
and they are progressive because what
they're trying to achieve is communism
yes yes what you're trying to achieve is
Classical liberalism and that's what you
had and that's where you're trapped in
this country with people who are at war
with you because they literally are just
psychotically obsessed with the end goal
of Communism and they find any roadblock
worthy of being destroyed no matter what
it is but a component of what they do is
reactionary and that they're trying to
rewind the clock I think we talked about
this a long time ago that the United
States uh uh maybe maybe not it's one of
the first countries with the concept of
individual meritocracy with without
without uh based on race national origin
religion Etc and the left is trying to
eliminate that they're trying to rewind
the clock to a time before we had this
classical liberal system that allowed
individual Merit
yes but the thing the thing is before
and after won't be the individualistic
classical liberal Republic you're
thinking of but the left are not trying
to go back to what was prior to the
United States they're trying to get to
an idealized future that they think will
come afterwards technically I would say
I would say I would say overwhelmingly
yes but that's why I say a component and
that is reactionary that's why a lot of
these words describe only only specifics
uh when they're honest with you you guys
are the reactionaries here right because
you want the 1776 America no no I
disagree do you know what the 1776
America I had a high fever it was not
good well but but it depends
technologically obviously you want
things the answer is no I don't right
politically so it depends on what your
definition of progressive is right I
think that when you look at where this
country is that's the question right
well okay they talk about oh we're
progressives progressing where right
what so that's why I would say no I
actually want a changed future right I
want I want I think that that's uh we
need to
amend the Constitution
to clarify things and make them better
now I understand the political realities
of amending the Constitution opening the
door to your enemies two-thirds but
imagine if if there's a culture War and
the Communists are defeated and just
totally give up and they're not a
question anymore and the uh
constitutional Republican Republicans or
republicanists whatever you want to call
it say hey how can we we can how can we
amend the Constitution to improve upon
us it doesn't happen again for instance
the Second Amendment can be can be made
to include literally any any any arm any
accessory quite literally we need to mix
but I also want to point out that you
know I don't want to go back to a Time
pre-women suffrage I don't go back to a
time when a constitution was written
about the rights of men when men were
enslaved I don't want to go back to any
of that I want to see the realization of
uh our moral values I wasn't speaking to
I wasn't speaking to the literal point
of 1776 but this is the point I was not
trying to go back I was talking to the
spirit of the thing right but obviously
the Amendments came afterwards but so
and obviously they're good so if we're
saying reactionary as in go back to the
way things were that's a bad thing no we
don't want to do that no no I'm not I'm
not saying literally go back in time
what I'm saying is you're trying to
restore the Spirit of the American
Republic as it was originally conceived
because all of the good things that the
American Republic was conceived of all
of the founding fathers knew would be a
consequence of the American Republic
they just didn't have the political
Capital to be able to do it right there
and right agreed like all of you know a
lot of well not all a lot of the
founding fathers own slaves but wanted
to abolish slavery and things like this
right and so they knew that this was the
path that this would end up being done
on and so you want to return to that
Spirit but the thing is the progressives
have got a different interpretation of
this and they say okay yeah we want
freedom too we want freedom from
everything right freedom from Hunger
positive Freedom yeah and so they they
they their their version of progress
their ideal view of the future is
essentially what you could describe as
communism it's the freedom from
literally everything and you're trapped
in this country with these lunatics
right this is half your country that are
absolutely batshit that have
stigmatized the human body itself as an
oppressive thing reality itself is is a
form of Oppression as so now what do you
do with them like what how do you deal
with that well so
in terms of describe descriptions of
reactionary otherwise it's almost
pointless because you can make the
argument that everyone else is more
reactionary like to to what degree the
question is the the moral loading on the
on the terms I mean to be a progressive
say well you want children to be
completely liberated from any
relationship with their own parents
that's not that's horrible I don't if I
if it makes me a reaction we say no
children belong to their parents and
they should need love and care for each
other then I'm a reactionary well right
but but should we should we we can we
can be dark with it I think we're
winning you want to know another reason
why I think we won because the left is
substantially more likely to abort and
sterilize their children and the right
are encouraging people to have families
and have kids of course they control the
schools and also but look at what's
happening in this country with a
cultural shift with parental rights and
education look at the Loudoun County is
is literally 30 seconds away from this
building 30 seconds boom you're in
Loudon if you want to go to where the
schools are you drive a little bit more
but the parents are showing up and
they're saying hey we don't want this
stuff and the laws are getting passed
across the board now there may be
conflict between the the cult and the
free people of the United States don't
get me wrong but there's a major
cultural shift where uh this this is the
data that I often cite because I covered
this several years ago in the 2000s
studies several studies showed liberals
were having 1.5 kids conservatives are
having 2.05 surprise surprise 20 years
later you have Pew research showing
slightly more conservative young people
only a tiny tiny bit yeah which is which
is a marked shift because typically each
generation is more Progressive now
you're seeing parental resistance to
what these schools are trying to do
you're seeing more and more people like
us watching shows like this and others
saying outright no to this education
system advocating homeschooling and pod
learning and actively uh participating
in their school boards
with that in mind with the conservative
base and the Libertarians and the
post-liberals knowing they're coming for
your kids they are in trouble because
they don't have kids the same goes
socialists don't have kids they have
yours but if these families have become
a prize to this and have begun to push
back and resist now it's danger danger
territory for them because they don't
have kids I really feel like I really
like I understand what you're saying but
I feel like the the left wants fewer
people so the fact that they do yeah
that's why they're gluing they want to
the sidewalks yeah exactly they want
significantly I believe that they
probably want around a million or two
human beings on earth like P like that's
really the goal that 500 500 000 500 500
500 million okay
okay they're doing D growth exactly
that's exactly where I was going
degrowth because they don't believe that
the the world can support it but but the
thing about the parents the one thing
about parents and I've talked to moms
for Liberty about this and I've talked
to other you know parents rights
Advocates
um parents go to school board meetings
parents talk to teachers parents like
you know deal with all of that stuff and
it doesn't matter that the Department of
Justice called them domestic extremists
it doesn't matter that the you know FBI
sought to investigate parents parents
just keep showing up because the stakes
for parents are way too high you know
once you have a kid like you look at
your child that's not just your future I
mean it's their future it's your future
it's the future of you know their
children it's so much more important the
question I have for everyone who listens
to this show do you want your children
to live in the Pod and eat the bugs yes
or no
so that I I it's not that it can't be
one I just don't think that well I'm
just going to broadly term the right
even though that is deeply inaccurate
right of characterization I can't
Freedom faction the just the opposite
it's the opposition to the left right
that really is what we're talking about
I'm just going to characterize it as the
right to the the ease of the
conversation resistance the resistance
the the problem they have is if you were
to look at the organizational capacity
the resources the number of people that
the left has active right now all over
the place uh it's staggering how much
more power the left has on the right
right I mean the the parents do have to
show up but the thing is there's only so
many times they can show up there's only
so much time they can take off work
there's only so many there's only so
much money that they could collectively
gather together to have like a lawsuit
against some Soros funded or whoever
funded billionaire activist organization
and these people being paid and will
always be paid and not only that like
treat this like a crusading faith and so
they get up in the morning Desiring to
do this you're trapped in this country
with essentially a bunch of religious
termite but I understand this but did
you know the founding fathers of the
United States thought that we would lose
the war for independence sure they were
saying many of the same things in a
similar way they were saying we can't
possibly win yeah you can't go against
the crowns impossible in fact we uh I
was reading about Lexington and Concord
the shot heard around the world and the
reason this is considered so pivotal for
the American Revolution was that prior
to the uh to the battles of Lexington
and Concord which were more of just like
like a handful of farmers fighting cops
essentially yeah basically no one
believed there would ever be arms raised
against regulars sure it was just no
because you have the Boston Massacre
where they're throwing rocks and stuff
basically a riot
and then
well a lot happened we'll put it that
way but this idea that simply because
you are up against Goliath means David
can't win I just don't think is correct
I think the issue with uh just a quick
thing here no one's coming to save us
right you had 16 000 French troops come
on that's true French French
professional church that's why we these
these were the best in the world right
the French troops at the time the best
in the world right and they were at War
they were fighting war against Britain
that's not yeah they weren't helping
where did we get that there's a lot of
veterans no no no no but it's not it's
not literal yeah it's not literally you
know where where where is the support
that's going to come externally from an
interested party who actively wants to
defeat the left it'll be the other way
around it'd be like U.N troops because
but it's not literal troops we're
talking figuratively where's the
cultural efforts the resources right the
resources needed to win whatever War
you're in if it was you know and see
it'd be boats if it's on land it's
troops but it's cultural fighting here
and it's a kind of social war that's
going on where could the reinforcements
come from
we have we have gen Z like gen Z is more
conservative you know the kids who are
coming up now are more conservative they
have a much deeper interest and you know
their basic rights and also thinking
that all this stuff is trash they look
at their gay teachers waving flags
around and they roll their eyes with
disdain in in the in the analogy of the
American Revolution you're correct we we
only won because of France but just a
quick thing mostly
what's the reading level of gen Zed the
reading level I don't know yeah right I
don't know I don't know about that like
yeah my son over the weekend was like
Mom do you know Hamlet I'm reading
Hamlet and I was like by by all means
good yeah but you're you escaped yeah I
escaped don't you homeschool your
literally December and no I don't
homeschool my child
in the in the direct analogy of the
United States we can point out the U.S
needed support we needed help sure uh
Quebec uh Quebec said no way we're not
getting involved and they would have
been the 14th colony there were other
colonies but in this instance I'm not so
sure we actually need that if the the uh
informed class of people in this country
are continually shifting away from The
Establishment narrative
it's going to be more V for Vendetta
than American Revolution sure it's going
to be that scene where the inspector
says eventually someone will do
something stupid and then it shows the
finger man shoot the little girl and
then the locals come out and say we just
don't care anymore and they got baseball
bars and crowbats baseball baseball bars
and Crow beds what the baseball bats and
crowbars V dies though right
yes but to be honest V chooses sure that
was kind of the point he was done he was
tired and so he decided to confront
um uh what's the guy's name uh oh uh the
VP I I know the guy right I can't
remember his name I remember creedy yeah
um and I remember was it Prospero is it
what was that no problem
yeah I remember him yeah yeah but anyway
anyway the v v didn't have to he he you
know he he confronts sure but the point
is it's not about V himself right you
could maybe that's Trump you can say
Trump is it could be she's could be he's
happy but I would love to have an AI
movie generator just replace V with
Trump
he's like fighting and you couldn't do
that that technology exists right the
right doesn't have the right mindset to
win the war that's the thing because the
rights fighting to be left alone and
they're fighting to exterminate
play out in other countries I mean I
think of like Eastern Europe and Georgia
right now they're both very
pro-nationalists pro-natalist countries
that Argentina guy right I mean I think
we do see it on an international scale
and so they want to be left alone but
they are seeing their values echoed
other places yeah but the the problem is
um these are all essentially what you
can just characterize like the great men
of history there's one guy right it's
one guy who's like in Argentina I'm
gonna do all this stuff okay maybe you
will be like an Alexander the Great and
you'll conquer the entire Machinery of
the Persian Empire but if you fail that
thing is just gonna swallow you up right
and so you're putting a lot on one guy
like they don't have the organizational
capacity though let me pass let me give
you another historical reference to a
conflict fought over one group trying to
be left alone and one true uh one group
trying to uh control the other you know
that that references in American history
it's a civil war okay the confederacy's
initial moves were a secession leave us
alone we out and they lost and then what
happened was the union said not gonna
happen yeah then this caused a major
Freak Out Among several more States like
Virginia which were they were they were
two to one in favor of staying with the
Union until Lincoln was like nah
actually we're gonna pull we're gonna
conscript people and we're gonna go
fight to suppress the Rebellion they
triggered more four more states to be
like this has to stop
this is funny because the Confederacy
could have won in the First Battle of
Bull Run but they chose not to invade DC
okay after the Confederates won and
shocked the North and pushed them back
they said that's it gentlemen we got it
now we'll be left alone and they were
wrong yes and then not not to say
anything like the Confederacy was
predicated upon ridiculous obviously we
don't support the Confederates ideas but
this is just an example from history of
how this works and that's the thing that
I'm really concerned about because like
like I just said the people who want to
be left alone they don't win the wars
well what's interesting though is the
people who want to be left alone we are
looking at a similar sort of situation
with the states rights fight because we
have a lot of States who are passing
laws that are Banning you know trans
stuff abortion
um yeah who are like making dangerously
split it's dangerously split but that's
sort of what we're looking at now that
abortion is a state's rights issue the
trans kids stuff is you you know not
elucidated in the Constitution therefore
it's a trans therefore it says states
rights issue and there's other issues
with that regard to education and stuff
like that so we are seeing things
solidify down States lines let me let me
pull up this story it's from the post
millennial New York City to pay over one
billion dollars to house illegal
immigrants over the next three years oh
boy enjoy that yeah they say with the
migrant crisis in the Big Apple showing
no signs of slowing down anytime soon
mayor Eric Adams has proposed extending
the city's contract with the hotel
association of New York the plan to
house illegal immigrants until August
2026 is expected to bring the project
cost since the Crisis began to 1.35
billion dollars my manager is having an
aneurysm right now in New York well we
should be so people are outraged and
there's a video from this morning where
the police arrest the locals protesting
the non-citizens being paid and brought
into their homes not literal homes their
their neighborhoods is this Roosevelt
Hotel no this is Staten Island okay in
Staten Island locals came out and said
stay out of our communities and the
police arrested them Michael Mouse is
not wrong about police oh yeah he's
totally right blind approved it those
cops held those cars there as children
burned to death and they they don't they
don't they release something on your
side by the government they don't know
or care and look people misunderstand
this they think that the idea that a cop
would do this when Michael malice says
when Michael malice says that police
will commit there's there's no crime so
egregious police officer we're not
committed up into including the
execution of children what people think
he's saying is that cops are smirking me
what he's saying is that a cop will be
told don't let these cars leave and they
go sure thing boss and then they're all
roasting alive he's like oh that's
what's happening that's what Jordan
Peterson talks about with the Nazi
officers and and what people are saying
now about what's happening in New York
and the immigration crisis
they bring in non-citizens they then say
you can be police officers Illinois is
proposing this they then say how would
you like to be a citizen all you got to
do is join the military join the
National Guard now you have loyal uh
people with no loyalty to the
Constitution or the country being
promised personal gain to subjugate
anyone who would stand against them we
already have that I mean you can already
earn citizenship if you're an illegal if
you're in America that's not my point my
point is if you do it on Moss we have a
really big problem I understand that my
point is not that we allow people to
become citizens to the military that I
get my point is
if a right if an American citizen is
questioned will you take up arms against
your neighbor they'll say no outright No
One Believes that police would do these
things because the assumption is the
police officers are consciously deciding
to harm a child
the real issue is that the police will
follow orders without understanding what
the full ramifications are and just do
it but there still is a problem of
American versus American but you bring
in non-americans Empower them with law
enforcement capabilities and weapons and
they'll say I literally don't care about
you at all I'm getting mine and there's
all of these young men these young
military age men that we see crossing
the border
um just wandering on it and not caring
at all the bite Administration will
maintain that it's actually families in
these points right even though they're
not and then also what happens is these
young men in a lot of cases when you see
them with families these are like cartel
manufactured families no they're not
really you know they're not actually
related they're not actually involved
with one another
um yeah I think this is really scary the
Roosevelt Hotel also has been taken over
by the city and is used to house
migrants exclusively and what's really
interesting about that is the Roosevelt
Hotel is owned by a Pakistani company
Jacqueline toboroff for human events
uncovered this for us it's owned by a
Pakistani company that New York City is
paying for the privilege of housing
migrants in it
and I'm nervous about a lot of hotels
like going to stay in a hotel in New
York who are you going to end up being
with a bunch of people who are living
there like cooking on hot pots in the
rooms and like what's going on hotels so
we in in Britain we've been dealing with
this for a couple years now you guys
have a barge right didn't you guys set
up a barge nope we've done jack no
there was a barge Rishi soon I put up a
barge oh it just didn't happen yeah so
in in Britain we're paying three billion
pounds a year to housing and hotels and
there's a local migrant hotel near our
offices near the load seaters offices
and we walk past there every day to go
and get our lunch and it's full of
Africans we're just sitting around
smoking and drinking with a very
suspicious collection of bikes that are
tied up these bikes are all quite old
and Rusty looking some of them got flat
tires these guys have been in the
country six months how did you get such
a rusty bike in six months you don't
think they brought their antique bike
collection with them yeah I don't um but
this is costing us money and if you go
on the website for this particular Hotel
it's just booked in perpetuity the whole
thing right so the government will just
book out the entire hotel and perpetuity
so you actually don't have to worry
about having to share a room with them
or anything you're in no danger of that
because you're just paying for their
holiday
how lovely perpetuity how lovely so are
we going to take we're taking our cues
from Britain on this one too
unfortunately yeah really quite a shame
it's really really annoying and uh for
some reason our government won't do
anything about it but again okay so
coming back to the previous Point what's
the right plan how are you retaking New
York are we going to build a wall around
New York no it's not a business it comes
back to the whole thing you can't be
asking to be left alone they won't leave
you alone what's the plan to take New
York the plan well to take New York I
don't know I don't know of an immediate
plan but the best thing that I'm aware
of right now is to do everything we can
to get the the Communist influence out
of the the globalist Communist influence
out of schools right now okay get out
good but but like that isn't a soon
thing
yeah New York used to have like
California as well used to be a
republican place like they sat there
with them they they had a plan and they
had the money they had the resource and
they had got the activists they had the
will to drive out their opponents and
they've done it and they will sit that
will never be Republican again it will
it will always be this kind of card yeah
Texas is purple State man and yeah this
this creeping Advance has always been
the plan and they're successful so
what's the right plan to roll it back
how are you taking care of your castles
no one's got no one's got a plan no have
you played uh we need a Grendel no what
we need is billionaires do we have what
are the right-wing billionaires doing
like I completely
agreement millionaires here's what
they're doing Brothers where's my money
how much money have you been given
I've been given none exactly neither
have I one well you know to be fair some
rich guys did give me uh they're cool
dudes they're they're I I want to make
sure they give you a handshake and a
beer right no I've been given a thousand
dollars uh uh maybe five six seven years
ago I got when I was just the small
YouTube channel when when you would post
I was 100 000 Subs I did have a patreon
a patron who gave me 500 bucks a month
that's amazing and uh uh almost a
billionaire guy yeah but uh I I will say
there are a handful of dudes that
definitely deserve credit for for
pushing back but I will also say I
question this all the time how is it
that Tim cast bought 36 Billboards in
Times Square last year 36 that the year
we we had What's called the North End
domination which is the entire North
Tower on New Year's we were in the
rotation of ads where every I think 90
seconds the whole thing except for the
McDonald's I love that you had lucrative
that's right and Michael malice yeah
yeah because I'm like this is our our
push into the cultural spaces this uh uh
the the total cost I believe for two
weeks of the North End domination run
with New Year's was two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars we are no like
that's a lot for us oh yeah and I'm
wondering where all of these other
powerful people I'm not even talking
about billionaires millionaires Yep
they're not doing anything like this
where are the right wing ngos that are
training activists to have a slate of
arguments and instructions in order to
go into institutions and start turning
them right wing but let me let me know I
have a question for you have you played
the video game forbidden West Horizon
forbidden
I haven't I even heard cultural
reference but I'll keep it simple for
you sure uh spoiler alert for anybody
who hasn't finished the second game that
came out several months ago uh the world
ends AI robots go go Rogue destroy the
planet that's game one yeah game two
you're in Silicon Valley Los Angeles
area uncovering more data you discover
that there was something there was a
military operation that everybody
participated in everyone it was they
were giving everyone weapons and saying
You must fight because we need to buy
enough time for our super weapon which
will defeat the AI the the Rogue swarm
and so everybody said let's go
a young woman a hacker discovered there
actually was no super weapon the program
was actually a terraforming operation
that Humanity would be killed and
everyone be grinded into Pace but they
needed to make sure that everybody gave
their result that gave everything they
had because if if that 60 year old man
didn't take up and fight back to buy
more time then they would not be able to
build the terraforming system which
would eventually give Humanity a rebirth
right the point was
many people were without hope and ready
to just lay down and give up and
although they did not believe they could
win they needed to tell everyone you we
are winning you will win do not give up
otherwise all is lost so I my point is
this
I genuinely believe we have gotten to
make we've begun to make such massive
cultural strides Victory is genuinely
possible I think that's true I also
think it's important to point out being
off being as honest as I can we cannot
maintain the idea or promote the idea
that we've lost already we can't win
there's no plan and nothing you do will
work because then what happens
there was a viral tweet where someone
said no one is trying to solve the
problems they're only trying to get rich
enough the problems don't apply to them
anymore yeah and when you tell people
you have lost and you can't win then
then everyone says well then what am I
doing so I'm not trying to say that it
can't be done what I'm saying is given
the way that the war works now the right
is just not equipped to win the war
that's the problem it's we know exactly
how this war can be won because we can
see exactly how the left is winning it
the problem is that right has just got
no organizational skills and no defined
end goal like the the if the right
should have some clear view of what they
want the country to look like because
the left absolutely have a clear view
it's just monstrous well right and
they're working they're working to
implement this and so the right knows or
should know by this point it needs
billionaire backing it needs ngos it
needs an army of bureaucrats and it
needs weird obsessive people on social
media to constantly reinforce every
single thing this structure does and it
needs to start consciously trying to
take care Apostles like institutions of
influence and maintain them actively
gatekeep against left-wing people
infiltrating them in return which is
precisely what they do and make sure
that every like I mean you look at
universities where something like 95
percent of professors are left-wing like
that okay where's the 95 right-wing ones
where are these institutions the right
has already lost almost everything
and there's one and there's one right in
Florida but let me let me tell you about
Charlestown West Virginia West Virginia
the second most Trump supporting state
in the country where you have signs not
even in West Virginia in Western
Maryland you have signs that say Maga
Trump Flags everywhere you're in West
Virginia sure Jefferson County which is
the Eastern Panhandle is still
substantially more Progressive with a
lot more Democrats and liberals coming
from DC but it is still majority Trump
supporting Charlestown West Virginia
passed a pride month resolution and the
residents are outrage and Furious but
guess what they don't vote and so uh
Sheamus was here and there was a large
Christian Catholic procession where they
protested I don't know if it was just
this issue and I talked to a member of
the city council because there's only a
handful and he and I said there were
thousands of people protesting in
Charlestown that the city passed this
resolution for pride month and he said
they don't vote why don't they vote
because conservative people on the right
don't organize they don't organize they
don't this is so this is what we're
doing right
we're building anti-time Square we're
building the Public Square if you know I
I say that because it sounds awesome but
you know I got to talk to Public Square
if they if they're happy with that and
uh first thing we're doing is we set up
a coffee shop and that should be opening
in a few months
it's getting pushed back because of
Permitting it's hard to do and uh second
floor Social Club Tim cast members
you're gonna have a blast we're gonna
have you know like a bar we're gonna
have you know card tables whatever we
can legally have I don't know we'll see
we're working on the card tables
um you better watch movies hang out work
on projects then we're going to set up
cousin T's Diner Terence Williams gonna
have a gonna have a pancake restaurant
we're gonna do Papa Jack's Pizza Shack
Family Pizza Restaurant we are going to
create this whole strip which is
effectively a parallel Times Square
small town protecting the generational
businesses that have been there
my goal with cast Brew Coffee we're
working with Andrew gruel on a franchise
plan is that we we get people who are
interested in the mission here's our
plan for infiltration in all of these
places we set up a coffee shop in strip
malls in every major city wherever
people live and they're interested in
doing it when soccer mom who doesn't pay
attention all that much is on our way to
pick up the kids from soccer practice
and says I need to get me a cold brew
she types in her little Google map
coffee and Casper coffee pops up right
next to the Target she drives in and
walks in she walks the counter and says
I'll just do a large cold brew it's like
you got it and as she's waiting she's
looking looking around there's TVs on
the wall playing Stephen Crowder and
she's listening to the conversation from
these shows or Viva Fray or trigonometry
and she's sitting there she's getting
their costumes thank you and she looks
up and they're saying here's the video
of the barisma Scandal that no one wants
you to know about here's Joe Biden
saying he didn't she goes huh and that
is how we get cultural hubs all
throughout that's a great start but then
think about how far Advanced the left
are in this war yup absolutely we've I
know I'm not like I said I'm not saying
we can't win I'm just saying it's going
to take some actual leg work and and
this is what we're doing but I will add
this this move we are making with uh
beginning the uh beginning the process
by which we can franchise Casper
the left has not done this what the left
has done is infiltrated existing
corporations and that's powerful but
there's something more powerful in
they're like the parasite ants they
don't have that they don't have the
support
what they have is clever strategy they
move into West Virginia claim to be
conservative and then get on school
boards and start corrupting and
destroying from within but most people
oppose them what we have is patriotism
which means people are actually willing
to work on a project like this because
it means something so you're saying like
where are the with the ideologues who
are like gonna you know just just get
into the pro like start working on this
and just dedicate themselves to winning
they're here and and we've got tons of
requests for people who want to open
these shops we just need to get it's
legal paperwork and all the different
things that's great that's a great stuff
yeah but but here's where I agree with
you
timcast does not have
that much money relative to the tens of
billions that they have but not not them
I'm saying like I don't want to drag
anyone in particular right now
but there was a meeting in Austin Texas
with billionaires and almost
billionaires and I was there with some
some friends
um
and they were talking about solutions to
how do we win the culture War and the
problem was these people and I mean this
in the quite literal and most respectful
sense quite literally I believe many of
them are autistic in that they have a
general light sense of autism they don't
understand social cues social issues
cultural issues their entire approach
was technological and analytical and
they don't understand how you win a
culture war and so I'm there with some
very prominent culture Warriors and
we're like guys listen Okay I said you
want to win the culture War someone
needs to just give Michael malice like
10 million a year and just say like you
are can you imagine the damage to the
left Michael malice could do with
funding that is a huge thing though I
mean money is a huge part of it you know
because conservatives need to be okay
with losing money in order to win
elections and win culture and right now
conservatives for the most part are not
you know they look out at the you know
whatever their Enterprises are and they
say let me just hang on to the money let
me just you know Break Even or whatever
they don't really they're not really
aware of the fact that if you're going
to win any of this stuff you have to be
fine with losing money all of these big
leftist organizations lose money
constantly but the benefits think about
BuzzFeed BuzzFeed when a Pulitzer on the
Steele dossier they lost all their money
all the time
what the left is after and I truly
believe this is access to power so it's
proximity is what the the payment is all
the power but that's why they can lose
the money that's why BuzzFeed can
because BuzzFeed doesn't care about the
dollars because the only thing money is
good for is exercising power right
nobody wants money just because they
have money nobody wants dollars for
dollars nobody wants pounds for pounds
they want money because it it
facilitates exercising power so if you
can if you can how much money a barisma
spent on Hunter Biden just to get access
to his dad but but the so what what
they're doing is essentially they're
foregoing the actual cash like buzzfeed4
goes cash to be in good graces with
people in positions of power and right
now the right doesn't have that like the
right has there's there's the only
person in a position of power not in the
government but the only person in a
significant position of power that a
right-leaning person could go ahead and
and try to get access to that that could
help them would be someone like musk
well maybe maybe Joe Joe Rogan I would
argue too that there are conservative
billionaires conservative wealthy people
who sent their children to Liberal Elite
institutions and then our influenced to
not speak out I mean I I know personally
from when I saw as a fundraiser there
are a lot of conservatives who are
saying well but my my kids would be so
upset if I donated to this or if I did
that or the other and so you are have
this family pressure to not do anything
and I think that is sort of the
cowardice we have to shed moving forward
I think ultimately there are a lot of
reasons why people want to hold on to
their money and especially if you lean
conservative you tend to be family
oriented so probably you want to pass
down your money to your kids but if your
kids are all voting for Joe Biden May
maybe it's not good enough to hand it to
them maybe that's not worth the
investment
you you'd be thinking why is my child
become a communist and I'm a republican
what have I done wrong who has done this
to them surely you want to take revenge
on that person I'm sure you want to be
like right I'm going to make sure that
person never works again right how dare
you do this to me you know that's what
the right should be thinking to the
right is just like well I just only rock
but uh leave me alone in a minute so
then the right is going to lose with
this attitude so what do you think aside
from things that like that like you're
doing with lotus heaters it'll be like
Tim's doing here what is it that you
think the right should be doing
um right the right the right should be
trying to craft policy right but the
problem with that is that you need an
affirmative ideological goal in order to
be able to craft a suite of policies and
the problem with not having affirmative
ideological goal is that it really comes
down to ultimately the right has to have
more than just liberalism right it has
to be more than the government isn't
allowed to tax me or take my stuff right
has to be what should you do today what
should you do and the problem with
liberalism has no answer to that
liberalism is an entirely negative
Doctrine and this is why like
Christianity was considered to be a core
part of life for the original classical
liberals because that did have a
normative doctrine of action and the
doctrine of action that the left has is
is all any number of varieties it's
World format exactly it's totally
changing there's no limit to the scope
of what the left need right and so the
right needs to be looking at themselves
and go okay what is it actually that the
world should look like and really what
it should be is safe for children right
that should be the watchword of the
right we're going to make the world safe
for children oh sorry got some gangsters
I know they're arrested oh what about
the human rights okay repeal that safe
for children oh there's some people in
El Salvador oh 50 000 March frog marched
through the street humiliated back to
you know back to back heads down whipped
as they go the humiliation safe for
children humiliation for criminals right
this is what the right should be saying
all day every day if you find anything
because now suddenly you have a mandate
what are you doing over there oh I'm
coming over there you're I'm
getting you safe for children
that's really good right this is why you
put me in charge yeah I'll tell you I'm
just saying that are you looking for
like a specific confession or just
general generally just generational
perspective just for a year well I think
you could get that I think in the spirit
of uh the Good Will of our neighbors
across the pond when we look to this
culture war and we seek an ally akin to
the French that intervened on our behalf
perhaps it will be the British maybe I'd
love it if it was the case
because we are so wouldn't it be
cool if we could be like the British are
coming and it wasn't like
yeah the British are coming it would be
nice but this this has to be the right
needs it's rallying Christ and I think
making the world safe for children is a
really great one because it encompasses
literally every aspect of life yeah like
that's a good one like when I was a kid
man you would just go out you would just
go out you would just go and your
parents were like look get out of the
house I don't want you around yeah come
back when it gets dark oh you're hungry
right have you read the first the fourth
turning so uh this is exactly what it's
talking about it's talking about our
generation of like you know the sort of
gen xers who grew up uh kind of nomadic
with our parents just having no idea
where we are with literal advertisements
coming on at 10 pm saying Do You Know
Where Your Children Are you know they
had to like what crazy times
that they had children but it talks
about how that generation that grew up
like that would grow up to say to the
world let's make it safe for children
yep that would be nice because we should
be that's the thing and how could you
argue against it right well exactly
who's arguing against it I can and well
this is how the left have won everything
because I've been like oh you're a
racist I'm not a racist you can't argue
against that right so we need our own
mimetics like that but so I disagree
with the uh I agree with the general
idea you're saying because I understand
you and I know what you mean yeah but we
have to be careful to avoid snow plow
parenting create that helicopter thing
and creating a soft generation of weak
kids who are scared of everything but
right now
but he's talking when he says safe for
children he's saying it should be safe
for children to be in the world
helicopter parenting means that you're
protecting your children yeah and it's a
perfectly good distinction to make but
but Phil you're exactly right it's safe
for children to go and explore yeah
right they're not going to get kidnapped
they're not going to fall into a gang
they're not going to get drugged up
yeah yeah
it takes fathers that are capable of
violence to protect their society in
order to make it safe for children and
that means that you need men we gotta we
got to do a moderately hard segue
because I do want to talk it's okay
Russell Brand so this is a story from
Yahoo Russell Brand uncovers Twisted BBC
conspiracy to collaborate on big stories
and other news outlets this is what I
was talking about right it's a funny
um misinterpretation of exactly what
Russell Brand is actually saying they
say in what seems like an awful lot of
the classic magicians trick where you
direct the audience attention one hand
so you don't see what's happening in the
other Russell Brand hopped on Rumble for
a new episode of his Daily Show Stay
Free and reveal that apparently
Independent News organizations are
secretly collaborating or conspiring to
control Global News narratives in some
of the most important stories in the
world gasp surely that is way worse than
anything else that may be going on right
now here's the point the idea that news
organizations were colluding with each
other on stories was a scandal when it
came out it was the journal list do you
guys remember this came out in like
2011. this is old news uh so the journal
list there's more than one yep uh
journalists at various organizations
were on a Facebook list with each other
where they were sharing all the stories
hence all the organizations
organizations would put out the same
stories around the same time that's a
scandal it is corruption
what they're now saying what they're now
saying in the presses oh can you believe
it so stupid if it's totally normal they
do this yeah it's it's old news this is
my point is it's the cycle of first
you're crazy it's not happening yeah
then even if it was happening it's not
even that bad then it's well it's a good
thing it's a good thing and now we're at
the it's a good thing that news
organizations all cool with each other
to to control the narrative I mean
what's the fourth estate even for right
normally it was for keeping the
government honest for expecting money
for big Pharma yeah now it's attacking
private citizens like the the NBC
article they tweeted it out right going
oh Russell Brand attacks the British
government oh no not attacking the
brisket and the good yeah good I hope
it's gonna I hope it's got something
it's like oh we better rush in to
protect the British government exactly
all these private citizens
yeah exactly the private systems
criticizing the government um you're an
American company aren't you in favor of
that I mean we're supposed
let me ask you as a as an actual Brit
yep many people people have said you
know because I asked like who cares
about Russell Brand is and people are
saying that it's front page tabloid news
it's a huge deal in the UK yeah break it
down for us what it's like in the UK I
mean it was literally one on on one
particular day every single Paper
whether left-wing or right wing had
Russell Brand as a rapist but but but
why Russell is he really that big in the
UK no not ready
the thing is
there are a lot of things here right so
Russell Brand is famous in the UK but
he's not on TV anymore right he hasn't
been on TV just reruns right no no not
even reruns because Russell Brand got
really famous in Britain probably about
20 years ago something like that doing a
show called Big Brother's big mouth
right he did he did a bunch of other
stuff but this was the one that I think
it's the most notable and the thing is
that's not the sort of thing you do
reruns on because it was a commentary on
Big Brother the TV show oh it was on so
you know you wouldn't really he was just
commenting on a reality show yeah yeah
yeah exactly right it was always meant
to do podcasting yeah exactly yeah no he
probably was this was before podcasting
even existed exactly and uh and to be
honest with you right I don't really
like having to defend Russell Brand
because he is annoying right he
he was I don't know right because we
only had 40 four TV channels and
channels one three were really boring
right and so you're like 17 18 years old
you've got to watch channel four oh it's
Russell he's so annoying he was just
insufferable but I have to say he has
changed a lot you know he has matured
and actually I've been watching his
content recently actually it's quite
consumable right um and so and possibly
because I agree that he's right on the
general thrust of his message which is
of course anti-establishment like the
rest of us yeah um and so good I'm glad
that he's sort of come over to this side
and there's there's a distinct advantage
that he has his because in 2015 the left
was trying to say look we're going to
use Russell Brown to reach the youth you
know the youth the listening to him um
but actually not really so much the
youth and listen to him it's 40 year old
women who are listening right this is I
mean look at his matching his messaging
very feminine but he's got a particular
way with women and you can see it in his
hands and in his Cadence and in the way
he gives them his total focus and is
accessorizing right yeah yeah he dresses
it really is very he's fam accessorized
exactly right and so like but if you
think about it actually the way that the
left works
they use middle-aged white women as kind
of Stormtroopers they do absolutely they
they use them really really aggressively
the wine moms yeah that whole thing yeah
because they're deeply invested in a lot
of left-wing um presuppositions and
axioms and and these were the feminists
exactly they've committed their lives to
these things it's like look you know I'm
gonna grow old alone and I've had a
bunch of abortions and I've got triple
digit body count right and I have to
defend my lifestyle rather than thinking
guilt exactly if you nail me on all of
this then I realize that I've wasted my
life and I'm a terrible person and
Russell Brand speaks to a lot of this
sort of slice of the population and I
think really they're trying to poison
him against them and weirdly enough
there are loads of like 40 year old
women who are coming out and defending
Russell Brand because they've been a fan
of his for a long time they have
absolutely and so it's it's interesting
that he has been attacked in this in
this way now right it's now that is the
the issue but to be honest with you this
could have happened at any time because
Russell Brand did these things
why is a member of parliament writing
letters to various networks well that's
the point and that that really is the
big question isn't it because it you
realize that the left's control is
entirely predicated on a kind of magical
spell that they cast Over You yep it's a
kind of it's just words that's all
they've ever used and just the word no
would have stopped all of this all the
time right just the word no would have
would have stop them every hurdle but
they were of course like no oh you're a
racist you're a big and you're like God
no don't accuse me unreasonably no
no I hope we'll pass this right when the
left accuses you of anything it's
because they hate you and want to
destroy you that's the only reason I've
ever done it just left yeah exactly you
just go well whatever you know I think
you want to molest kids
down the companies that do the
advertising a lot of like Rumble exists
on Advertising Revenue no it doesn't
doesn't it Rumble right now I think for
the most part existing is is existing on
investment but why is Dan bongino
freaking out freaking out yeah the
longevity he's been pretty upset on
Twitter about like the attacks on Rumble
I think I I think Rumble is predicated a
lot of the revenue is likely coming from
uh subscriptions when people sign up for
locals that's a big component they're
operating off a lot of investment and
how much was burking even spending on
Rumble with 44 million unique monthly
visits nobody ever I mean no I just
think to scale to compete with YouTube
you do need the advertiser ever now so
of course stand by Gino should defend
the company it would be the stupidest
thing to I said I don't care about
advertisers no you should be like
they're attacking us and they also went
after X they also went after Twitter
they grabbed like 60 of the revenue I
mean it does matter that these activists
are going to corporations and our
boycotts are working and it's that the
it's that the media companies rather are
going to these corporations demanding
that they retract their advertising from
certain sites and that seems to be
really egregious this concept of the
good corporate citizen needs to go we
don't need good corporate citizens we
need good corporations we give Burger
King the Bud Light treatment yeah Burger
King like we call it yeah we keep
boycotting things that I don't buy
anyway it's really you know the problem
when when the adpocalypse happen with
Pewdiepie
um I remember reading an article that
described how YouTube YouTube's
advertising model worked and it said
that there was something like six sort
of advertising conglomerates so a
company will go to this conglomerate and
say I want however much money spent on
YouTube and they'll be like right here
we'll get it sorted for you and so they
have like stables and advertisers and
one of these apparently threatened Paul
from YouTube and YouTube then collapsed
them back down on everything right
because it's never been a profitable
platform but but think about this and
this is true for for Elon and Elon is
doing exactly what I advocated for
during the first adpocalypse if
Coca-Cola
comes to YouTube and says look man we
got a bunch of angry emails about
PewDiePie saying naughty words if I was
YouTube I would be like we've apologized
for it we've told PewDiePie like hey man
you got to watch yourself you can't do
this he said it was an accident he's
very sorry but I appreciate you bringing
it up that's really great when can we
expect your renewal and then when Coke
says no if you don't Implement these
changes and do what we want we pull I
would respond with oh that's too bad
Pepsi just came to us with a billion
dollar offer for ads it'd be a shame if
there was no advertising for Coca-Cola
and it was just all Pepsi but you know
we can arrange that Pepsi and Coke both
send you an email then my response is so
uh it would be really unfortunate if the
largest Millennial and gen Z social
media platform had all of its creators
complaining all at once about how their
money disappeared and our responses were
so sorry it's Coke and Pepsi who made
the choice that to support you what do
you think is going to happen to the
younger generation when every single one
of their celebrity Heroes comes out and
says never buy this trash again you want
to go to war you will lose
the platforms but Elon Musk and Elon
Musk now understanding what YouTube
didn't decided to go to war and say we
will come after you oh where they're
suing right yeah and he says go by all
means Elon Knows X is the water cooler
and if they want to pull ads he laughs
and says we provide revenue streams to
some of the most influential political
commentators in the world what do you
think is going to happen when and I'll
I'll just me yo I post pictures of trump
stroking a chicken and I get 250 million
impressions per month that means my my
my stupid little post gets scrolled
through by people that many times Elon
knows this and he's smart and so he can
go to these advertisers and he can say
what do you think's gonna happen if you
pull your ads and this guy right here
he's a liberal he gets a billion views
and he's a fan of ours what do you
think's gonna happen when he tweets out
to all of his liberal fans that you guys
are betraying the spirit of what of what
we're working on it's going to whatever
you whatever money you think you're
going to lose by advertising on our
platform with with nasty speech you will
lose 100 fold for coming out against us
the thing is they'll make a moral
argument that will make it Justified and
Noble for them to lose whatever money
you threaten with them to lose right and
so they will come across as the big
Winners and then they've got the entire
media machine that will start saying oh
you know Noble heroic international
corporation it well they've already done
it I know you're saying there's a
Tipping Point basically it doesn't
matter because when you look at 30
billion dollars lost Bud Light and
Target are being sued right now by a
political shareholders who are like why
would you do this to my money and now
you've got you've got hedge funds and
and investment firms that are being like
this is a we just lost how much
percentage of our portfolio for all of
our clients and our clients are are
Furious right now we can't risk
investing sell sell sell now Bill Gates
comes in Bill Gates and starts buying a
bunch of Bud Light
probably because he's like thinking he's
gonna buy a dip or he's like they need a
rescue they need somebody to turn around
but when it comes to this at a certain
point you must recognize that you might
not have the winning hand but you have
the winning play so I I haven't made a
poker reference in a long time so I'm
going to take the opportunity right now
yeah
you you go to a low stakes poker table
and No One Believes when I say this
if I if I get dealt trash cards
so second best hand in Texas Holdem
pocket kings two kings in your hand I
have gotten people to fold the second
best hand simply because I bet one
hundred dollars and then they're like I
can't do it it doesn't matter if I have
an 80 chance to win I don't want to lose
a hundred dollars in one hand and they
will fold and then I'll flip over seven
deuce the worst garbage hand and I'll
say I know I'm going to lose but I can
put pressure on Elon Musk can look at
these farms and he can say I know we
don't have near the capital to go up
against all of you but I know you're
more scared of me than I am of you
here's a better example I remember when
I was driving I was a little kid my
dad's in a Jeep Wrangler Bare Bones
steel frame no bells and whistles and
some luxury sedan is trying to cut my
dad off and my dad laughs and he's like
yeah I'll call your bluff dude you're
not scratching your luxury sedan on my
hunk of junk rusted Jeep and my dad just
carried on ignoring him so this guy is
putting pressure on this guy with a
really nice car and my dad's laughing
like you think I care about this hunk of
junk is it so my point is this
Elon Musk might not have the best most
powerful play but is Coke willing to
take how much how much economic damage
are any of these advertisers willing to
sustain because elon's like it's my
existence
I have no choice if you want to lose
five percent fine so be it but if we do
nothing we cease to exist so we will put
all of our resources up against you and
you know what you might lose five
billion dollars is the 5 billion worth
it to you and they're gonna say
I don't want the headache man the left
operates off of creating a headache for
people yeah they call and they say
whatever so this is what happens because
conservatives Libertarians post-liberals
whatever are we are are so quick to just
back down and say please leave me alone
the left knows that applying any small
amount of pressure results in a victory
if we counter that and simply say
10 so so we were doing an event and they
started calling the venue and the venue
said screw off we've had we've had a
bunch of this happen recently my answer
is simply look guys we've worked with
you for x amount of time you make money
working with us you've gotten 30 emails
likely all came from the same person I
assure you if you cancel the economic
hit you will take will be worse than
ignoring 30 emails and you know what's
happened over the past several years
they say we get it we get it we're good
don't worry about it the the problem
with all this is this isn't happening in
isolation because if it was just these
things moving on the board then yeah
you'd be totally right but they have a
huge International apparatus that's
currently moving against our chess
pieces the international part is is key
too I mean look it's the British
government going after Rumble that's
right you know it's States and Rumble
already told I think France yeah they're
already banned in France right but the
thing is then but then you get the
European Union because France a major
player in the European then they're
going to start moving against like alt
Tech as well and they're just going to
slowly grind us down because we don't
have BlackRock backing us you know we
don't have the media backing us we don't
have every celebrity backing us I don't
think that matters I I I really think
they they operate off of complacency
yeah they do yeah and it is a fact that
any amount of pressure breaks the the
mental will of the average person who
doesn't want to be evolved this is
involved this is what the left operates
on yeah so like I was saying earlier
what I've been hearing more and more
over the past few years first with 2018
into 2020
I'm talking to people and they're saying
things like I want Trump to lose because
I am sick of hearing about him I want
the fighting to stop
Trump loses it didn't stop now these
people are saying they won't go away
bring Trump back so he can crush them
and finally make it stop what people are
starting to realize is the promises of
the media stopping what they're doing
and the the government stopping what
they're doing it was never about Trump
and so now the attitude is Trump's not
even President Biden's screwing up
across the board we've got war and
crisis and they're continuing the
pressure in the conflict why won't it
stop Trump says I'll make it stop and
now people are starting to say fine the
Normie doesn't want to be involved and
the left use that to their advantage to
get them to side with them but then
after they won they would not stop they
kept pushing and pushing and pushing so
you're totally right the argument for
Trump has never been stronger right and
it's really great that it's literally
not even been four years yet it's not
really great but it is the case that it
strengthens Trump's argument for himself
that Joe Biden has literally demolished
this country demolished the
international order demolished America's
historic reputation as a world power
it's genuinely upsetting to me as a fan
and friend of America to see what this
country is like degraded to and I say
that as my own country's falling apart
around me as well right it's happening
everywhere and it's part of this sort of
international cabal that is doing this
right and that's great and it is nice
that the ground has never been more
fertile but the thing is like
a disorderly mob is no more an army than
a heap of building materials as a house
right there has to be structure I agree
and organization and and like like it's
not that we can't win and I'm I'm
telling you we can and we must win but
we need to start thinking about right
okay who's gonna start doing these
things you know who's going to start
actually right we need someone setting
up an NGO and recruiting 100 activists a
month now I'll tell you I'll tell you
right I'll tell you right now stuff like
that going on I mean if you look at
Turning Point action you know Public
Square USA if you look at Public Square
if you look at some of the initiatives
with regard to voting in the upcoming
election you have people saying let's
put like let's do ballot harvesting on
the on the conservative side let's put
ballot boxes in the back of churches
that stuff all works that's all
effective
100 times more of it you know how long
the American Revolution took oh
um eight years or something 20 years 20
years all right started I believe it was
19 uh I'm sorry 19. 17 64. was the
beginning of what we described as the
revolutionary period and could you
imagine
and then the first battle started in
1775 and then a year and a month later
the founding fathers signed the
Declaration of Independence so so hold
on there a minute
a decade of people being oppressed and
beaten down and nothing and then it's 11
years later
when the when the regular is coming to
Boston and say it's it's simplified 10
events Boston Tea Party there was uh was
it the Tea Act or whatever made it
easier for the East India Trading
Company
yeah the British crown was trying to
basically essentially bail out the easy
Trading Company to a certain degree
that's how we view it and this made it
more difficult for American tea
producers to trade and they're like
you're bringing in this teeth from
outside here when we're trying to trade
here so they dump it into the ocean the
crown then says you got to pay all that
back they say no we don't and they say
then you are in rebellion and we're
deploying regulars to Boston to get
things under control so then the people
in Boston said outside of the city we're
the law then the regulars were like were
ordered go take their weapons away they
are not the law and these people said
enough and then the first shots were
fired and there was no ordering and yet
nobody knows exactly who uh according
according to the stories they say it's
not sure who fired the first shot but I
believe it was the Americans who fired
on a regular and may have killed one of
them it's interesting because it's
entirely possible
my point is my point is it a lot of
people are screaming 1776 blah blah I'm
like dude the history of the American
Revolution is not like a bunch of
founding fathers got together smugly and
proudly wrote these brilliant things and
said there must be Independence bang to
gavel delivered to the king and the
keyboard
the King was sending troops to the to
rebellious colonies for a decade before
fighting actually broke out so what
we're looking at right now with the rise
of Public Square One of the most
powerful tools you're making a great
Point here as well because it was an
awful lot of pamphleteering in coffee
houses that sort of raised Consciousness
and that's really what we're doing here
like I said the war isn't over and it's
not that we've lost we need to know what
we need to do to win it you know we need
to be serious about the scale of the
opposition I mean it literally is
something akin to the British Empire
that we're staring down here you know
it's a giant clothes Globe spanning it's
a culture I remember that John Adams
defended the British soldiers in the
Boston Massacre because he believed in
due process
and those kinds of those kinds of
natural rights and freedoms
I feel like a significant problem and we
talking you know talking about schools
earlier that's where the the big
disconnect is we've raised multiple
generation generations of children that
do not hold even the the founding
principles they don't even know the
founding principles they don't know why
property rights are important they don't
know what happens when you take property
rights away from a society they don't
know why the rule of law like why
innocent before you know innocent before
proven guilty is important they don't
understand because they haven't been
taught they've been taught almost
exclusively the worst thing that can
happen is someone could say something
racist you might someone might
understand what you say as being bigoted
as if the worst thing that's possible
the worst thing that they can imagine is
hurting someone's feelings and this is a
massive massive problem in our society
yeah I agree with that as well I mean I
think that's why we had what happened in
Canada I think people don't understand
history they don't understand the
implications of you mean they're not
saying Parliament because they said oh
well he fought Russia and we hate Russia
now the everything is measured by a
modern standard and it leaves especially
Young's generation completely lost I
think your Point's completely valid I
think the right does need to decide what
they are objectively building towards if
you don't have a blueprint for a
building it's going to be very difficult
to come up with something and ultimately
I think that's why the right is unable
to organize because they don't share a
common vision and I think
furthermore that's because we think oh
we'll just let everyone be on their own
and they'll make their own decisions and
they'll have their own values and
everything will be fine and we know
that's a failing system but I think Tim
Tim I think you're making a really good
point that I hadn't really thought about
to be honest um that is a great Point
20-year War man and we're in the early
stages with the coffee houses pamphlet
Turing right now I mean I don't doubt
that the King's Men would have gone into
a coffee house and taken all the
pamphlets and beating all the people in
there spreading around that and we're
those guys who are getting whacked with
the stick now and that's and that's fine
but but fortunately we've got to carry a
pro back we've got to keep conflicting
fortunately for those who are meeting
and having conversations uh to this
degree about winning culture War
building culture
we're not actually having the King's Men
come into our homes and take from yes
right but we have a third amendment so
we're still practiced to a certain
degree but what we are dealing with is
censorship and so they are ripping the
papers from us and you know kicking
people out of the out of the out of the
Public Square as it were but uh I'm
grateful that it is not violent conflict
and I and I hope that doesn't come to be
the worrying thing is with things like
January 6 and with the 529 far left
attacks on the White House these things
it's worrisome Aaron Danielson being
shot twice in the in that was his name
right Aaron Danielson you mean with when
Michael reinold did it shot him twice in
the chest these are scary things and so
a lot of people I will tell you this the
last thing anyone needs right now is
real conflict what we need right now is
in the truest sense of the founding
fathers yo writing pamphlets yeah and
using pseudonyms and spreading the ideas
and building the sentiment that
eventually led to a shatter of
confidence in the crown and then the
people in this country were like look
where the funny thing is the Declaration
of Independence the reason we say that's
the birthday to this country despite the
fact that it was actually you could
argue the Treaty of Paris which was I
think was 1883 was that what it was 1883
the Treaty of Pierce yeah I don't
remember uh was it true to Paris when we
were basically like
okay that's fine the crown will stop
fighting to the American people the
moment we said we were independent we
were to the crown uh-uh it wasn't until
yeah I mean George said they would never
accept it September 3rd 1783 yeah 17.
and that was the official end of the
American war for independence where the
British crown finally recognized okay
you're independent but to us we are
independent for six years before that
sure but that's but I I think you're
totally right like the modern version of
Panther theory is obviously these
podcasts right yeah so you know we are
all doing great work but I think we
can't be allowed to fall into
complacency and think oh wow we need to
need to do much else right because like
the scope of the problem is well and
this is the issue that same people are
like we're not winning we're not winning
they say it over and over and over again
Donald Trump said that uh you know the
election was stolen it was stolen and
then people didn't show up to vote in
Georgia and what should have been easily
won a senate seat for a republican went
to a Democrat somehow with all the
polling and and there were interviews
done where guys outside were like what's
the point they stole it anyway and
Brianna Wu said she ran Trump's
statements at as advertisements in
Georgia I think said in Georgia or she
used to statements advertisements I
don't know if it was in Georgia because
Trump was suppressing the vote by
telling people you are losing my point
is we have gained strategic grounds we
have tremendous victories in the culture
war and now we need to like when when
the when the enemy is breaking ranks you
don't say all right that's it everybody
time to pack and you say you say charge
yeah so now uh Public Square is one of
the most powerful tools and look I'm not
talking about I've never even heard of
this what is this Public Square is an
app where in order to have it's a list
of businesses and in order to be on it
you have to agree to American values if
you say I support Free Speech the
Constitution families things like this
and uh so Casper coffee is on Public
Square we're huge fans they're
sponsoring our Miami event they um I
think they did they did a SPAC deal so
they went public they're tremendously
successful and they're basically
creating an anti-amazon they're going to
you you download the app it's pretty
cool oh it's amazing everyone download
Public Square you download the app you
sign up you search for businesses in
your area
America I believe so far but they're
launching in Canada pretty soon so check
it out well because what's going to be
is going to be like traditional British
values in the UK I think so but I mean
we could literally the the standard
would be do you agree with the values of
Magna Carta that's literally literally
where I mean this this whole thing with
Russell Brand is actually a violation of
the Magna Carta like this is literally a
textbook violation check this out okay
you pull up the map and it will show you
all the businesses in your area that
support your values that sounds great
and so this that this maximizes by cut
potential so for us in in you know West
Virginia I know a lot of businesses
support of ours they haven't heard of
Public Square we got to get them to
figure it out because we can pull up
restaurants and we know that by them
being on Public Square for one they're
probably fans so we know we're gonna be
welcome there and we know that our money
is going to go to someone who's helping
their children who believes in this
country and we keep the money in our
parallel economy and we start to strip
the resources from the what Corporation
but it's probably because it's not
available
and an anti-amazon and their success is
just this example I'm talking about
organizational capacity that's such a
good thing is though you know the left
is going to see this right yes of course
they're gonna be like uh we don't think
so what can they do well they can take
you out all it is is an app that sells
jerky shirts and pancake mix they don't
need a reason I agree
yeah exactly right so like there are
going to be challenges ahead but that's
a great idea and a great step forward
and it exists and it's really great it's
right there uh download Public Square
yes that's Victory right there let's go
to super chats if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends head over to timcast.com click
join us the members only show is going
to be spicy we have a story that is very
brutal deals with crime and wokeness and
this one's going to be well said in the
uncensored members only so uh I hope I
hope you guys are there and uh so go to
timcast.com click join us sign up 10
bucks a month and then we're gonna have
the members only show on the front page
at about 10 05 or so pm
and we're gonna take calls from you guys
the members but this is this is a big
story that broke today that we're going
to get into the Nitty Gritty on and uh
spicy story Clint Torres says howdy
people howdy Clint you got the first
Super Chat hey
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim women who
think Real Housewives is worth a wasted
second of a man's life need to get back
to reality AKA making sandwiches for the
boys boys that's right
so we were uh so this is based on the
segment I did about the Roman Empire
thing yeah women being surprised that
men think about the Roman Empire but uh
it's because in the article if I'm
loving the post the woman says you know
a guy said that the the Roman Empire
offers us lessons but so does the Real
Housewives and I don't think about that
all the time and it's like oh man what
lessons does the Real Housewives offer
I've never seen it yeah I don't really
know I'm not really sure that's our best
argument here are they real housewives
though I think they're probably not real
housewives right I mean they're on
reality TV so it's All Phase to school
and they're making pbjs and I don't have
any ideas or are they like wine moms
sitting around complaining about I spent
too much time living my actual life that
I'd watch that show it'd be funny if
we're just making fun of it because we
don't know it's actually a Super Bass
show with women it'll be really
interesting I'm willing to exactly
talking the Roman Empire
yeah we were making that joke earlier
that like doing a bit where it's a bunch
of women sitting around with wine being
like well Hitler's first mistake was
invading Poland obviously I mean he
didn't have to
I won't make a joke I accidentally made
yeah no no yeah the jokes before the
show members only yeah all right where
are we at Mr uh batalana says damn
barely got here and I'm not first Tim
what are your thoughts on Trump wanting
a Glock compared to an American-made
firearm
I mean Glocks are reliable and simple
but uh Trump he should have gone
American and I think um Springfield
Armory they they moved out of
Massachusetts
he could have absolutely gone for like a
good Springfield 1911. I took my first
uh class there at that at the Armory
there that's a bummer man nothing wasn't
moved out of Connecticut too they're in
Knoxville
the Springfield Armory Massachusetts
making the guns for the revolution it is
frustrating that Trump doesn't Telegraph
this stuff though right because like
that would have been a signal you know
hey I'm paying attention I mean he's 78
or whatever it is so you know maybe you
can't blame him but he didn't actually
buy the gun uh candy nice
so someone tweeted that he bought the
gun and then they deleted one of his
staffers deleted it and then said he was
actually just looking he didn't actually
buy it because they didn't have trouble
it's got a picture of him on it yeah he
can buy it it can't be sold to him oh I
see it's illegal to sell a firearm to
somebody who's under indictment for a
crime that has a longer than a year
sentence possible as a potential
potential which I think is
unconstitutional and should be yeah and
there have been several federal courts
that have already said it's
unconstitutional it just hasn't been
officially ruled on I suppose
all right
where are we at Dead Eye 22 says I may
not be first but just wanted to say I
found you through sergeant of akkad and
I found Sargon through teal deer oh wow
deep blue here yeah deep lore
all right Matthew Hammond says what
significantly changed in the UK for the
better after leaving the EU
well I think there's a very strong
argument that brexit hasn't really been
done uh and the problem that we have is
the same problem that Trump had really
that there is a massive deep state that
is entirely almost remain and does not
want brexit to be a success and so
nothing particular has changed but the
thing is as well shortly after brexit
they're of course covered in the
lockdowns so it's actually kind of hard
to extricate what the consequences of
one or the other are because they happen
so close together and there's been such
catastrophic Damage Done To The World
economy generally so it's really hard to
say because of what a the
whole thing has been
we got I'm not your buddy guy says I'm
glad I found you during gamergate you
helped me find like-minded individuals
who respect Classical liberalism keep it
up at Lotus Eaters cheers well thank you
very much oh yeah
Cal H says love you guys I started
listening to both Sargon and Tim around
2014 definitely a positive voice in my
life just out of college bring back twis
that's basically what the podcast is
we've got a YouTube channel obviously
called podcast
my 2014 content though is just travel
stuff doing the travel docs for uh Vice
and then Fusion I enjoyed Thursday yeah
uh the the live stream stuff that I was
doing was massive and it's kind of crazy
like the the shift
and I think you know what I learned
when I started live streaming from
occupy and then traveled around doing
all these different streams was that it
was a live podcast on the ground I was
just talking non-stop for like five
hours at one point during act by 21
hours straight and so people are
listening to it as effectively and on
the ground podcast of a real world news
event and then it wasn't until
2017 I was like oh I can actually do the
same thing on video I don't need to be
traveling around everywhere but more
importantly what happened was I was
still traveling around but they came to
recognizable and so it was a gag to come
and harass the stream and make noise and
same thing happened to Andy no right
like he used to do a lot of on the
ground stuff but of course now he's got
like a million follows on Twitter and
antifa will literally hurt him he had a
bomb threat at his his speech just uh in
Virginia
all right get off my lawn says if Newsom
debates with the santus DeSantis will
crush him and Newsome's polling numbers
will tank I'm not so convinced
I'm not sold on that either Newsome is a
is is the used car salesman here
DeSantis he's very smarmy but he's going
to be he's successful with that and if
you if you like Newsome is smarmy but he
has more Charisma than DeSantis yeah
well you know so does my cat so does
Marcus
I like DeSantis because he's got great
policies his parental rights and
education bill was three pages long and
it it ruined the White House it was
amazing very good bill the problem is
newsom's basically like the
californian-american psycho right yeah
he looks like the American Cycle I know
it's crazy he looks like there's no
Humanity behind his eyes at all well
DeSantis said when when the first when
it got broached in the first place like
a couple months ago or whatever he was
like sure I'll bring my hair gel
that's pretty good which isn't bad it's
not bad yeah that's not bad I was like
oh hope hope but a lot of psychos are
really good at manipulating people and
that's the problem I think the Newsome
will be able to beat DeSantis on the
sort of Charisma battle right you know
all right and I say this is like a Gen X
artist you know I like DeSantis because
I see a lot of myself in him he's
relatable yeah yeah for me but not for
most people
Jason Dixon says Tim please shut up the
Discord again we are building culture we
have a live watch party and interactive
member only shows uh you guys if you are
not members of timcast.com you should
become members not only do you get the
uncensored show which is going to be
really fun tonight
but you get access to our members only
Discord where there are watch parties
commentary after shows like after we
wrap the members only they have their
own after dark show in the members
community and yeah I'm super excited for
this we're gonna have a physical
location if you're a member we will have
a physical place where you can come hang
out and if you're working on music if
you're working on video games if you're
writing a book if you want to hang out
with like-minded people actually meet
people and and share ideas and watch
movies
that's the plan man that is so cool
that's one thing that I really like
about maybe we'll be hanging out I will
hang out because I live around here
that's right but one thing I really like
is the building of culture that was a
that's like a huge deal to me because
that's what I miss so much about
um New York and that's what I miss so
much about the theater Community after I
kind of got kicked out I fully expect
feds to try and like come and hang out
at the club because they they of course
have memberships and they watch you know
we've had like Enrique tario and stuff
on the show but uh you know whatever
they can come hang out the point of the
club is literally to like you know paint
Warhammer figurines or whatever it is to
have a scene right yeah and you need to
see you know it's been a long time since
there's been a good scene like you know
I can I can identify moments in my life
like time periods in my life where I was
part of like really fun scenes and you
look back and you're like oh that was so
badass that was awesome it's just that's
what you're creating is a scene that's
one thing we're gonna play uh we're
gonna play Magic the Gathering nice yeah
I'll distress
like
I just I can't keep track and I find
standard to be pretty bad it's too
fast-paced modern's okay but for the
most part Ian and I when we do Play It's
just Commander the problem is our decks
have become so perfect and Powerful it
got to the point where Ian and I would
roll a D20 and then whoever got the
higher number we just shaking for that
good game because like at one point
it's like okay should monocrypt is
banned you know if you get monocrypt
then I don't you won so do I we can't
play with it okay and then it's like
okay well that card's got to be banned
too and then it's just
we can't do it but uh sorry Carl now if
we play Commander you would you post
playing Commander but if we play another
format I reckon okay see everybody
listening you're saying like nerd stuff
but I'm telling you we're gonna have
this club we're gonna bring Carl out
we're gonna have just like a cool
hangout playing Magic the Gathering and
ordering pizza and if you don't know
what that's about you could just sit and
have a cocktail with me and that'd be
fun too yup that's right or we'll talk
about the romance
they're even more entertaining while
playing D I think that's talking smack
or magic talking about I don't know see
see here's a thing I've played D before
and vampire I've played those games DND
is just hanging out making jokes and
having fun I don't I I've only played I
think we played like twice okay but I'm
everyone tells me that basically all
Dungeons and Dragons basically devolve
into lewd humor and people having drinks
with their friends that sounds why I
played because that was a lot of fun
that's what we did yeah it's like magic
is going to be an intense power struggle
between the two of you yeah okay
D is is tremendous fun tremendous one
because people think it's like you're
pretending to be a wizard yeah kind of
but we did a scenario uh I played it
like three times we did a scenario where
I just defied the the the game Mastery
dungeon master repeatedly and so he made
me drink my character drank sour milk
but then I started celebrating the
delicious uh cheese yogurt that that the
drinking like just no matter what he
said I was just being a dick you seem
like that kind of plan yeah that's right
the dungeons ruin your day
though yeah a smart dungeon master I
know I know you know because they it's
it but it but it's fun because you're
just making jokes the whole time
everyone's laughing Jokes Aside this
somewhere that people can come out have
drinks socialize play music yeah play
music you know I mean if you can get one
watch the show live because I'm being
afraid to tell people what you do for a
living yeah and just relax you know that
that sounds like a great investment man
yeah all right atheronzalez has Carl
been a fan for a while miss I miss you
this week in stupid segments they helped
me get out of a woke like phase in my
20s by showing people who had bigger
dumber gripes than me made me realize is
that how stupid I look thanks a bunch oh
you're welcome that's pretty cool
baby leg Bennett says ripped to my
chicken flock Fox got in last night
killed all of them but won I'll be
getting my revenge tonight oh that is
brutal
chickens are based man how are they
gonna get their Revenge with thermal in
a 22. I gotcha
whatever whatever
but we have a flag downstairs we sell a
flag and it's uh styled like the Gadsden
flag yellow and it's a rooster spreading
his wings that says stand to your ground
no I like that and uh the rattlesnake
was don't tread on me it was a symbol of
if you step on me I will bite you and
the rooster is the symbol of I love this
roosters will sacrifice themselves to
save their hunts and so I I take uh
issue with those using the word chicken
synonymously with cowardice and anybody
who has chickens knows this roosters are
like they're wild Maniacs yeah they're
not scary like they might be scared but
they will strike so I I remember I
walked in the coop and Roberto jump
kicked me I'm massive compared to him
and he's just like get away from my
girls they're just so stupid they're
dumb they're dumb but I I don't know
it's kind of adorable though it's an
issue of of
vigilance and it's it's I love dogs
represent loyalty better than anything
else the story of Hachiko the dog you
know the story Japanese professors used
to walk to the train every day with his
dog would go to school would go teach a
university when the train came back
Hachiko would wait for him and he'd walk
back together one day the professor was
at the University had a stroke and died
Hachiko waited for 10 years until he
died they it's more complicated that
they tried to remove Hachiko he'd break
out run back so they built a statue in
his honor dogs represent loyalty and
that is that is truly an amazing thing
you know chickens represent like what
how would you describe it when uh a
soldier willing to charge head first in
the battlefield knowing they might a
firefighter running into a fire to save
the children a fox will be approaching A
Flock and the rooster will charge full
speed knowing he'll die yeah but the
girls get get away there's a military
term for that called the full on hope
the the first into the breach in the
walls that's right you know you're dead
right but you've got the beaches at
Normandy yeah yeah yeah yeah
historically there was a military term
for called the full on hope you had to
go in and you were gonna die man but you
did it anyway yeah I think all the guys
hanging out in the keep when Grendel
comes in yeah yeah and so you get a
roaster like Roberto the little guy and
he's like willing to go to war with a
fully grown adult human male I'm like I
respect it yeah I respect it I'll kick
you away but
but yeah we have that flag because I I
love that representation of you have to
stand up for what you believe in there's
chickens all in my backyard they're not
even mine a what they just they they
escape from next door and they just run
all around that's great right and I'm
like we were here first lady I don't
care like there's that there's a
groundhog there's a bunch of when are
you gonna get your own chickens that's
the right direction I'm gonna do that
and homeschool my kid and run the
post-millennial at the same time but you
don't homeschool Charlie so it's fine
you should see what the struggle is try
and get him to do his homework and
practice piano and practice guitar
let's read this one from Mr Obvious says
we aren't winning we are resisting it's
not enough to vote in the next election
we must counter their cheating we will
have we will have one once we are in
power and have crushed our enemies Total
War yeah I just want to say Mr Obvious
um I don't know whether he's still got a
YouTube channel because they got banned
there's a really nice chap yeah it looks
like it yeah Super Chat verified and
everything I hope he does because well
worth your time he does Great Clips
definitely but uh
um I thought we lost this channel we we
need we need to do the same the same
things that Democrats did in 2020. you
know it's it's all by the game that's
what you do and that's it and then once
Trump's in office he can start weeding
up corruption arresting those who are uh
deserving of being arrested and facing
indictments and we'll go through the
legal process as we should but it must
be done it we can't do this this
half-assed McCarthy GOP type software
it's like we'll get to it you know
eventually no no no we're gonna go and
be like doj start filing you know
there's an emergency inquiry this week
right doesn't it start on Thursday oh is
that it well that'll be fun I've been
thinking of myself like you've been win
it then you can fix it not try and fix
it first and then try and win once you
have it's much more important
Alpha Garcia says Freedom loving trucker
here please shout out happy birthday to
my wife Lisa happy birthday Lisa happy
birthday I have to leave out on her
birthday and I'm forcing her to watch
you guys on my only day off well right
on thank you happy birthday
she's like is this what men think about
the Roman Empire
that's what we talk about
where are we at Cain Abel says Tim know
your history about the Nazi party and
Communist Party gain control how oh
about how the Nazi party and Communist
Party gained control we are losing this
war they can rig the election by placing
people in it they use their own power
which they have to win I disagree I I
just
I I can't understand how Trump is
winning in the polls uh Trump he
improved it for getting arrested he's
fundraised record record amounts of
money that Bud Lights dropped 30 billion
dollars at Target is dropping that
Disney's burning subscribers Disney lost
a billion dollars in their last 10
movies I don't understand how you look
at all that you're like man but we sure
are losing and I'm like look man they're
getting desperate and they're lobbing
everything they have at Trump to destroy
him but that's desperate that's that's
the collateral damage from those moves
reeks of of desperation
making a Disney movie that's woke and
making a bunch of money off it that's
them winning but that's turned around
now they're bleeding money over at
Disney the fact that they just tried to
destroy Trump's businesses right they're
creating so much collateral damage it's
pure Victory regular people are gonna
look at that and say these people have
lost their minds yeah they have it's
going to hurt them in the long run
definitely so it may be bad now but I'm
like these are these are these are signs
that your opponent is flailing in
desperation yeah I all I can think when
you talk about that stuff is as uh the
Princess Leia quote the more you tighten
your grasp the more systems will slip
through your fingers I think the more
that they do to to put their foot down
on people the more people realize yeah
you know I mean
they step on the on they see the
Cockroach they step on it and it
splatters all the eggs all over the
place deep into the carpets yeah that
happened to me with a spider in my
mailbox
I didn't mean to squash maybe a symmetry
y'all Hunter says hey Tim Sargon is
actually how I found your channels when
you guys did that park bench sit down
video all those years ago glad to
finally see Sargon finally on the show
thank thanks uh to both of you that's
right second time right no that's my
first time okay
we started when cover was locked down
and then even after that you couldn't
travel yeah so the vaccination uh pass
to get into this country for literally
years I was like no I'm not doing it I
was in Berkeley I think yeah and we were
covering what was going on the ground
and then uh Crossways went on vacation
and asked me if I wanted to produce a
video that he would put on his channel
and I was like yeah let's do it and then
I was like I could I could I don't know
what I'd do but I could do something
breaking down like how the media is
lying because I work I had just left and
so we did a video explaining like the
different ways they manipulate and uh
and then I went from like I think I had
like 40 something thousand subs and then
two days later I had a hundred and I'm
like I remember seeing the hotel lobby
is the thing ticked over to 100 I'm like
and then I'm like how do I get my my
silver medal like where what do I do and
then it took like eight months until I
finally got it and then I figured out
once you get your first you have the URL
to get the rest and all you need to do
is figure out the code and it's like I I
figure out a work around so all my other
channels I instantly as soon as I hit it
got the got the awards All That Remains
was waiting for India to clear something
for a year before we got our silver wow
yeah I don't know why I don't know why
but YouTube in India was holding
something up for for the band yeah but
you know yeah I know you know let's do a
big following in India I don't no I
didn't think so but and I don't know I
mean I'm not sure that there was any
following or if it was just something
that had to do with the legal department
or whatever you know yeah it would be
funny if like Hassan has the the like
Turkish equivalent of like several
platinum records
criticism of you is somewhat warranted
I just I can't imagine Hassan has any
Talent so
I mean if he wants to go to war with
Talent call you a failed musician it's
like you know what do you say he got mad
they got dunked On by a rock star so
it's called to a failed musician so
you're calling hasana for a rap battle
Yeah I would I will because I would love
to I would call Hassan out for a rap
battle you got to hear me do baby got
back again
okay Hassan the golden is down what you
doing bro apparently you ran away from
Sam Hyde but I mean I'm much smaller I'm
not a big guy you can't be physically
you're not even gonna get it punched in
the face this time you know so got no
excuse this time all right let's grab
some more Super chats Joseph says thank
you call for blackpelling this channel
they sorely need a reality check if you
really cared you wouldn't live in a
fantasy world so okay that's that is a
bit harsh and I'm not trying to black
people because I you are totally right
saying look
demoralization is the worst thing that
can happen and it is they're absolutely
right it and I'm not trying to
demoralize this but I'm trying to make
sure that we are realistic about the
scope of the problem and where we need
to begin from where we are to get to
where we want to be but you didn't know
about Public Square you know now that
you do now your mind's completely
changed you're like we've won it's over
well
a couple of months ago someone came on
and said this is grimcast I'm surprised
I can't make anyone happy that's like I
was on a war room with Steve Bannon once
and I said that he was very optimistic
and he was like oh my goodness someone
called me up
it's all a matter of perception I guess
yeah but I I kind of disagree I don't
think we need to look realistically at
the problem and determine the scope and
figure out like how we can actually
tackle it because the problem is so big
and the scope is so massive that I think
it would behoove us to look at it and
say we can handle that woman it's like a
little bit of a fantasy involved just so
that we believe that we can tackle it I
mean there's a great Point blackout
where um General Melcher I don't know if
you've ever seen black at her yeah we're
just going to pig-headedly ignore the
facts and press on anyway yeah that's
what we need to do and I kind of
appreciate it yeah there's a part of me
that does appreciate that but then
there's a sort of the cold-hearted
realist in me it's like okay but we are
gonna have to think about a lot of stuff
well you need you need a couple people
doing that but the people who are
actually going out there and like going
for it and going to the coffee shops and
downloading Public Square and doing all
that stuff and homeschooling their kids
like they need to look at it and say
like we could totally handle this you
guys yeah let's just link arms they are
actively handling it to be physically
handling it yeah I think so all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
more importantly head over to
timcast.com click join us the members
only uncensored show will begin in a few
minutes and we've got a spicy story
which is about the culture War woke
politics and the ramifications
pertaining to a woman who lost her life
it's going to be it's going to be a
little dark but we hope to see you there
and then if you become a member hang out
in the Discord help build culture with
like-minded individuals it's how we win
shout it again to Public Square for
sponsoring the Miami event download the
Public Square app get involved you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Carl do
you want to shout anything out uh well
just uh my outfit which is lucy's.com
and go subscribe to the podcast with low
teasers where we black pill everyone all
day every day but we also have some
solutions so that's lucky yeah right on
Libby hi I'm at Libby Emmons on Twitter
you can follow me there and you can
check out what we're doing at the post
millennial and human events and if you
really want to support Independent Media
and tell NBC and all these people to go
screw off you can do that you can go to
thepostmillennial.com subscribe and join
us follow what we're doing and you know
get some honest reporting where we speak
truth to power
I am Phil that remains on Twix I am Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains you can follow
us on Spotify Apple music Amazon music
YouTube you know the internet fifth gold
record fifth gold record wow couldn't
get to say yeah pardon me 106. well
that'll that's coming actually shortly
there's there's another one that's right
on the on the camera too yeah really
okay
classic failed musician uh I'm Hannah
brimlet I'm a writer for timcast.com you
should follow at timcast news on Twitter
or X and Instagram it's the best and uh
we're always happy to be a part of the
Independent Media space uh if you want
to follow me personally I'm on Twitter
at HC brimalow and I'm on Instagram at
hannahclear.b and serge is here too yes
and you can find me on Twix 2 at
surge.com uh it's a pleasure meeting you
in real life sorry gonna record for real
yeah I've been a fan for a long time as
with these friends and uh yeah I'm
excited for the after we'll see what the
questions are from the audience we will
see all of you over at timcast.com for
the uncensored members show in just a
few minutes thanks for hanging out